so Sam's 21st century adventure on the
big screen is an origin story so don't
worry too much if you're going in cold
just make sure you're paying attention
and enjoy the ride but even if you
aren't familiar with the characters
you're certainly going to see a few
familiar faces bringing them to life
here's why the cast of Shazam looks so
familiar
oh and just in case you haven't seen the
movie yet spoilers ahead seeing as he's
playing the super-sized version of young
Billy Batson otherwise known as Shazam
Zachary Levi is essentially the face of
the film and probably the most
recognizable face all around I'd like to
purchase some of your finest beer please
with any luck
Shazam will give the supremely talented
Levi that final push onto the Hollywood
a-list wondering where you've seen him
before
well Shazam is hardly Levi's first
superhero flick the actor last suited up
for cosmic action is Fandral alongside
his fellow warriors three in Thor the
dark world and Thor Ragnarok
it's far more likely that you'll
recognize Levi from his extensive work
on the small screen
most recently he appeared in the
short-lived series heroes reborn and
starred in the cheeky NBC sitcom
telenovela
he's also impressed with a serious turn
in Netflix's marvelous dramatic mini
series alias grace of course Levi is
probably best known for his work on
NBC's awesome off the overlooked action
drama D Chuck the actor brought some
serious geek energy to his charming
portrayal of a directionless post-grad
who inadvertently downloads a secretive
government computer program into his
brain and yes it's every bit as fun as
it looks
Shazam could also prove the first big
break for the actor portraying Billy
Batson the pint-sized version of Levi's
superhero
hey we're guessing that most of you
don't know who a sure angel is because
he's just getting started in showbiz
some of you may recognize the youngster
from his one-off role in the short-lived
spin-off series Criminal Minds Beyond
Borders a few of you might also have
seen angel as the second lead in the
2018 ballet drama driven to dance if not
those of you with the Disney Channel
might just recognize angel as the
conspicuously kind-hearted Jonah Beck
the family-friendly comedy Andy Mac
whether you're familiar with angels work
yet or not we're fairly confident you'll
be seeing his face a lot moving forward
possibly even in a Shazam sequel the
actor playing his precocious crutch
found best pal Freddy Freeman has been
on the Hollywood radar for a few years
now dude
just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're disabled
- Oscar kid you've got it all
his name is Jack Dylan grazer and he got
his first taste of stardom with a brief
appearance in 2015's chilling horror
anthology tales of Halloween he followed
that family-friendly outing with a
starring role in the TV series me myself
and I a comedy exploring key moments in
a man's life over three distinct time
periods with grazer portraying the
youngest version of the protagonist the
up-and-coming actor went from relative
unknown to impressive newcomer when he
joined the losers club as the nervous
overprotected Eddie Kaz Brak and the
brilliant adaptation of Stephen King's
it a roll grazer is set to reprise in
2019 hotly anticipated sequel in between
those horrifying blockbusters grazer
also booked the prime gig of playing the
adolescent version of Timothy Shalom A's
character in the indie hit beautiful boy
Grace Fulton is likely to be familiar to
quite a few viewers Bolton portrays
Billy and Freddy's foster sister Mary
Bromfield in Shazam and much like her
co-star Jack Dylan grazer in it
Bolton has likewise played the younger
version of a character in a film in fact
one of Fulton's biggest early roles came
as the adolescent version of ill-fated
Hollywood starlet Natalie Wood in the
2004 TV movie the mystery of Natalie
Wood she followed that role the
recurring gig is the younger version of
jennifer Love Hewitt's Melinda Gordon in
the ghost whisperer
later she booked a multi-episode gig as
the teenage counterpart to Madelyn snows
matriarch on ABC's revenge
of course most viewers will recognize
Bolton as one of the eldest of the
tormented orphans in 2017 chilly in
addition to the conjuring universe
Annabel creation
Shazam finds jamun Honsou playing an
ancient wizard who gives billy batson
the power to transform into Shazam
haan-soo spent the early years of his
career as a fashion model and backup
dancer in music videos for Tina Turner
and Janet Jackson among
any others Steven Spielberg used his own
wizardry to pull a heartrending breakout
performance from the model turned actor
in 1997's Amistad the film made an
overnight star out of Honsou who has
gone on to appear in dozens of films
including memorable turns in Ridley
Scott's gladiator the heart-rending 2002
drama in America and the fast paced 2015
action film Furious 7 even earning a few
Oscar nominations in the process if
you're wondering where you've seen Han
soo recently it was likely in the MCU
where the actor portrayed the Kree
warrior Korath in both guardians of the
galaxy and Captain Marvel speaking of
Shazam actors who have superhero
experience let's not forget about the
great Mark Strong the iron-jawed actor
plays the nefarious dr. thaddeus sivana
in this latest DC flick but Shazam is
far from strong's first turn as a super
baddie he actually played another DC
villain almost a decade ago and that oh
so forgettable Ryan Reynolds starring
Green Lantern of course strong may just
have a face for villainy because he
broke bad again as the vile Frank
D'Amico in 2010's kick-ass strong also
played memorable villains in the
big-screen adaptation of Neil Gaiman
Stardust and try not to forget the 2009
Robert Downey jr. starring Sherlock
Holmes where he played the evil Lord
Blackwood did you happen to catch his
performance in Ridley Scott's Robin Hood
where he played Godfrey rest assured the
role of the bad guy in Shazam is in the
hands of an extremely good actor
he's also starred in the Kingsmen movies
the 2008 thriller Body of Lies zero dark
thirty and countless other films the
actor playing the adult version of
Freddy Freeman will likely need no
introduction Adam Brody did after all
get his first big break with a
multi-episode stint as would-be rocker
Dave and Gilmore Girls his follow-up
role is the ever nerdy Seth Cohen on the
OC help the young actor a cheap full-on
teen heartthrob status I'm sorry if I'm
the only one here that'll state the
obvious but we have all this extra room
right we have a pool house Brody has
also made scene-stealing appearances in
movies like the 2014 coming-of-age drama
growing up and other lies Wes Craven's
met a horror sequel screen
poor and whit Stillman's damsels in
distress' dyed-in-the-wool horror fans
will most likely recognize brody for his
disturbing and hilarious turn as an
indie rocker with some serious ulterior
motives in the bloody diablo cody satire
Jennifer's Body Freddie Freeman isn't
the only one of Shazam's pint-sized pals
to get a superhero alter ego in the
movie in fact most of Billy's foster fam
earned spots in the super-powered Shazam
family the inimitable Megan Goods scored
the role of the adult Darla Dudley who
undergoes a truly radical transformation
throughout the course of the film if
you're wondering where you've seen her
before
take your pick because she's been
cranking out movies on the regular since
breaking into show business in the
mid-90s of her work in that bygone
decade most will recognize good as the
confused big sis and the coming-of-age
drama Eve's Bayou in the years since
good has racked up memorable roles and
TV shows like California keishon and the
sadly short-lived Minority Report series
she's also nursed a booming big-screen
career that seen her appear in films
like anchorman 2 the legend continues
and the entirely unfortunate 2008 comedy
The Love Guru and now I'd like to show
my love by making for you make a baked
pizza what's that pop-tart with the
ketchup and don't forget her
blood-curdling work in the horrific and
outright horrible saw 5 here's hoping
Shazam helps make a household name of
good of the actor's plane adults
super-powered versions of younger
characters in Shazam michelle borth
isn't one of the better known names
still that doesn't mean you won't
recognize the face of the future Mary
Marvel or Lady Shazam or just plain old
Mary aka Mary Bromfield though birth has
yet to find a legitimate breakthrough
role in Hollywood she's been in the game
for a couple of decades now hawk-eyed
viewers might recognize both for a
one-off appearance as Dean's significant
other in a trippy episode of
Supernatural
or perhaps you caught her in HBO's
relationship drama tell me you love me
odds are most of you know birth from her
60 episode run as Catherine Rollins on
Hawaii five-o and if you don't know
michelle borth from any of those
projects now's as good a time as any to
learn her name because you'll be hearing
it for years to come
just a few years ago most viewers would
not have been able to pick actor Ross
Butler out of a lineup
even if his six-foot to frame
unquestionably set him apart from most
of his peers while viewers may still not
have butler's name memorized it's a safe
bet they'll recognize his face from one
of several notable small screen
appearances over the past few years the
actor first started turning heads in
2015 when he appeared in Disney
Channel's action comedy KC Undercover
that same year Butler booked one of his
highest profile gigs when he claimed the
role of tough guy jock Reggie mantle and
the CW surprise hit Riverdale with an
obvious penchant for teen drama Butler
again played a tough guy jock with a
conscience and Netflix's teen suicide
drama thirteen reasons why though he's
yet to find his breakout role
Ross Butler is very much a star on the
rise and there's a little doubt that his
work as the super-powered adult version
of eugene choi will set his star a
little bit higher the actor playing the
father of Shazam baddie dr. sivana will
need no introduction to fans of the
superhero genre the DC Universe in
particular the actor's name is john
glover known for his giddily wicked work
as Lionel Luthor on the long-running
Superman in high school drama Smallville
in addition to his work as the Riddler
and Batman the Animated Series fans of
The Dark Knight should also recall
Glover space for his appearance as the
mad scientist dr. Jason would ruin
1997's Batman and Robin love it or hate
it
Glover's maniacally over-the-top
performance was unquestionably one of
the best parts of Joel Schumacher's
controversial farce if you manage to
miss Glover in those super-powered
flicks you'll probably still recognize
his face he's a beloved character actor
who's been working steadily in show
business since the 70s
among Glover's more memorable roles our
appearances in the oscar-winning drama D
Annie Hall in a hard life to die no I'd
like to get torn apart by wild animals
and let's not forget his stupendously
scene-stealing work opposite Bill Murray
in 1988 Scrooge oh and then there was
his equally delicious role in the 1990
sci-fi sequel Robocop 2
Magna volt the final word and although
security that's the same nothing of his
memorably hilarious turn is the head of
the clamp cable network and the cult
classic gremlins to the new batch
there's plenty of other roles worth
mentioning like his part in John
Carpenter's unheralded masterpiece in
the mouth of madness all we really want
to say about John Glover is that he's
one of those actors who makes us smile
the second he turns up on the screen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]